[Music]
what's going on guys you know there's
only one reason that I'd be wearing this
getup because it's time for the screen
E's the awards show that you know and
love let's dive into this crap
chill out dads this is the toughest moms
award the nominees are the tough mom and
I Tanya the tough mom from Lady Bird the
tough mom in the Florida Project the
tough mom and three billboards winner
the tough mom and mother if nothing else
she had to tough out being in the film
mother with an exclamation point fandoms
did so many ridiculous things in 2017 we
decided to give them their own award
their own sad sad award the first annual
stand prize named after that mm song
stand about that really intense fan and
the nominees are Star Wars the last Jedi
petitions to have it erased from Canon
Justice League fans petition for the
non-existent Snider cut guys who are
upset about all-female Wonder Woman
screenings wow it's been a long year and
the winner is Rick and Morty fans for
throwing tantrums over McDonald's
Szechuan sauce giveaway Congrats kids
you don't deserve the sauce and yet
don't deserve the show but you know what
you deserve a scream this one is a
screen E's classic the best mainstream
movie that sounds like a porno award
daddy's home to Captain Underpants
snatched XXX the return of xander cage
how'd it be a Latin Lover
the nut job too nutty by Nature Logan
lucky rough night good time and the
screen he goes to it comes at night
Congrats it comes at night you sound
like a porno this screening is called
the that came out this year award for
the film that the honest to god really
came out in 2017 and the winner is 9/11
starring Charlie Sheen and Whoopi
Goldberg
what's going on I'm clue Charlie Sheen
you've got yourself a screen II it's
time for the annual Tom Hardy greatest
achievement and covering your face award
previous winners include Tom Hardy and
the Dark Knight Rises Tom Hardy and Mad
Max fury road and this year's winner Tom
Hardy and Dunkirk Congrats on your
three-peat Tom Hardy and we're looking
forward to seeing you cover your face a
fourth time when you claim venom next up
is the that guy of the Year award the
award for the actor that made you say oh
hey it's that guy the most in 2017 the
winner with appearances in Fargo shape
of water call me by your name the post
it's Michael Stuhlbarg you know that guy
Congrats Michael Stuhlbarg and I
apologize if I mispronounced your name
let's just take it a stab this is the
biggest comeback of the Year award the
nominees the Thor franchise the
spider-man franchise David Lynch and the
winner is M night Shyamalan after
following up the visit with split you're
officially out of the doghouse
we've crapped a lot on Shyamalan around
here but gonna do it less this rather
prestigious screening is the baby
aestethic for the mouth most appropriate
for a human baby to have the nominees
baby driver boss baby the baby and
mother winner
Superman's weird baby mouth and Justice
League special thanks to Paramount for
not letting him shave the mustache
because digital artists had to rush a
tiny baby mouth onto a grown adult man
oh here's another screening the tender
moment between man and monster warg the
nominees are the shape of water weird
that that one didn't win huh war for
planet of the apes alien covenant and
the winner is Luke Skywalker gingerly
milking the force swollen teats of
whatever this thing is milk does a Jedi
good this next screening is the oh hello
your
the best award this is for an actor or
actress that you just became acquainted
with and then you instantly realize that
they rule and the winner is Tiffany
Haddish and girls trip Congrats Tiffany
Haddish
you're the best hot damn this is the
heroic Hollywood movie for a not so
heroic person award the nominees Tonya
Harding and I Tanya Tommy Wiseau in the
disaster artist and the winner is the
greatest showman turns out that not only
was PT Barnum not the greatest dude in
the world when it came to animals and
people but he also doesn't look much
like Hugh Jackman that's nothing to sing
about Petey you know what I'm looking
forward to my biopic starring Dolph
Lundgren Congrats on your screening
this is the best DC movie award and the
winner is Lego Batman Wonder Woman
inspired us all to be better and Justice
League inspired us to stay home and save
our money but Lego Batman delivered the
best Batman stories in years you know
what I'm saying it's time to jump start
the Block averse with connects Suicide
Squad and Playmobil Teen Titans you
heard it here first this one is the
Jason Voorhees award for the unstoppable
force that you just can't seem to kill
and the winner Johnny Depp who is still
releasing Pirates of the Caribbean
movies doing crap on the Orient Express
and presumably murdering some camp
counselors by the lake Johnny it's time
to retire and open up that designer
scarf store that you've been cosplaying
as for decades there's still time to
operate out of the next fantastic beasts
movies this my friends is the spin-off
we most want to see nominees Laura from
Logan the praetorian guard from last
Jedi Korg from Thor Ragnarok
winner Jim Carrey wondering if he should
become Jesus at the end of the Jim and
Andy documentary wonder what would
happen if I decided to just be Jesus
give it a whirl Jim he already did Bruce
Almighty you already grew the sweet
Bible beard thank you waiting for Jar
Jar Koosh ball the equivalent today
would be a poor Gidget spinner this one
is that you guys
don't deserve nice things award for
movies that should have been a hit but
weren't the nominees are
Logan lucky war for planet of the apes
stronger and the winner Blade Runner
2049 the gorgeous sci-fi intelligent
blockbuster that flopped at the box
office because we don't deserve nice
things guys these are all amazing movies
that tanked and now studios think we
only want Marvel DC and Star Wars movies
full disclosure I saw Star Wars 6 times
guess we've all got some blood on our
hands let's do better in 2018 have
another screening this is the seriously
make up your mind award two years ago we
awarded the make up your mind award to
Star Wars fans for hating the force
awakens for being too similar to a new
hope after hating the prequels for being
too different from the original trilogy
well this year the award goes to
Star Wars fans now apparently you didn't
mean what you said about force awakens
because this year the last Jedi came out
and made some changes to the universe
and everyone crapped their freakin space
diapers
seriously Star Wars fans make up your
mind I can't do this every two years my
blood pressure this is the best movie
foods award the nominees are the eggs
from shape of water pie from a ghost
story ice cream from Wonder Woman peach
from call me by your name grape fruit
from girls trip and the winner is t from
get out what anyone like t good job t
this very prestigious award is the Bing
Award for the best fake Google search of
the year the winner the bye bye man at
one point a character infected by the
curse of the bye-bye man goes to a
library to do some background research
you know just like you do whenever being
set up by a supernatural bad guy he just
searches bye-bye man without quotes even
but also they'd even take the time to
design the by by verse version of Google
those guys are using a generic search
also by the way by by man wins the award
for the movie that stole my damn
catchphrase I'm the bye-bye man
ooh this tasty little morsel is the CGI
that belongs in a video game from at
least five years ago award the nominees
are the boss battle at the end of Wonder
Woman the figure skating sequences in I
Tanya and the winner
Steppenwolf in Justice League Congrats
Steppenwolf you look like a character
from doom Congrats to all the winners
you did it and now before we go a look
back at some of the things that we had
to say goodbye to in 2017
[Music]
your movie sucks so bad
you sound real bad
Joan screwed
[Music]
it's your fault
we all want
your movie sucked so bad
they were
you sound real bad
don't skirt
[Music]
it's your phone
we all want
[Music]
well that was a good time so what we
miss in 2017 or you have any new
categories for screen ease let us know
in the comments section below I want to
thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram thanks for watching screen
junkies bye bye see bye bye man that's
mine
bye bye